this this is big news and it tells you a
lot that we do not lead with this story
Ronda Santa suspends his presidential
bid and endorses Trump this happened
yesterday afternoon uh Ronda gave a
speech where he accidentally quoted
Budweiser thinking he was quoting
Winston Churchill which I see as a
perfect U uh example a perfect uh well
how do I say this it explains his
campaign yeah it encapsulates the whole
thing yeah Success is Not final failure
is not fatal it is the courage to
continue that counts Winston Churchill
No in fact that was a bud Budweiser ad
from 1938 talking about fishermen
particularly young men who don't care if
the weather is bad they will try anyway
and uh Well Ron sure when we played the
video in the car we were driving back
home someone actually asked if it was AI
yeah I thought so too you thought it was
AI so good he was
smiling relieved the best I've seen him
look in months he looked like wow I'm so
I'm so glad that this is over he opens
with I'm in Florida and he's like happy
about it he looks like he's about to cry
hting yourself in the head with a hammer
it hurts so much when you stop uh look
he always lacked a rationale for his
candidacy what was the rationale for his
candidacy if you wanted the America
First candidate we already had that
person uh that was Donald Trump if you
have a choice of seeing the Beatles or
seeing a Beatles tribute band which one
are you going to see you're going to go
see the Beatles right so he never had a
rational for his candidacy other than
saying well something might happen to
Trump but that something hasn't happened
or to the extent that it has happened
it's actually turbocharged his campaign
so he had one foot in the America First
Camp one foot in the Republican
establishment camp but he could never
make a case why him other than well
Trump might be going to jail that's why
it should be me and that Trump is
beloved he is uh he's unlike any
political figure we've seen in the in
the history of the country let me let me
play a short little snippet from this uh
this antis speech first Snowman in New
Hampshire they are one of the reasons we
fight so hard for what we believe in
Winston Churchill once remarked that
Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
counts while this campaign has ended the
mission continues down here in Florida
we will continue to show the country how
to lead thank you and God bless so that
was the end of course where he quoted
Budweiser thinking it was Winston
Churchill but uh I agree he seems
happier than I've seen him in a long
time uh I also I got to be honest when I
saw this I thought it was AI I thought I
thought it was a deep fake AI generated
speech and some people point out that he
flubs a word halfway through the speech
and I'm like that's actually to me more
indicative of it being AI of it being
like autogenerated all you have to do to
make this these days it's really easy is
r could stand up say three sentences he
could walk up and just go how now brown
cow the quick brown fox jumps over the
lazy dog leave and then they can make
him say anything they want I am not
actually suggesting that's what they did
it's just I mean you thought the same
thing it would he talks like this and
then he'll go on and say another
sentence and then he'll continue like
this it felt very
robotic I think was that not the problem
of his entire KY likeability
is a crucial factor in politics uh and
running for governor is not the same as
running for president running for
government you can keep the media at Bay
you have to give that many interviews
you can control access to yourself much
tougher to do that when you're running
for president uh and in this particular
case this guy spent
$300
million uh and he dropped out a New
Hampshire because he had dropped below
5% of the vote and that was after
squeezing out a very narrow but distant
second place finish uh in Iowa and he
has long-term problems now in in Florida
where he's hurt his standing very badly
but what the hell's Nikki Haley doing
she's hanging on to try to be vice
president is what she's doing well I I
couldn't agree more but she is the
epitome of the Bush Cheney uh when's the
next foreign war wing of the Republican
party uh and uh they I think would try
to like try to force her on the ticket
uh I think she's going to get beat
tomorrow in New Hampshire by I don't
know 18 19 20 points uh and then we head
to her head State her home state where I
think she's going to get shellacked it's
not incidental that the governor of
South Carolina Henry McMaster very good
guy the lieutenant governor most members
of his cabinet most of the leaders both
all the leaders of their legislature
were all in New Hampshire yesterday and
today campaigning against Nikki Haley
the did it right the Campa igned for the
most part praising Donald Trump's record
and he actually did not give a good
reason for the longest time as to why he
was even running he ran he said we're
going to do these things and I was like
these are good things he defended Donald
Trump when bad things happened and then
only towards the end he said I'm running
because I think the Deep state will stop
at nothing to remove Donald Trump and if
that's the case the last thing we want
is Nikki Haley to be the only one on the
ticket and I said that's actually a
really good point I'll accept that but
that but I'll tell you this I I'm voting
for Donald Trump and only in that
scenario does that make sense and then
when he loses Iowa he drops out Praises
Donald Trump endorses Donald Trump and
campaigns for him and I'm like that's
how you get out of this he made a name
for himself from 0 to 8% wonderful job
and now he's launched a budding career
Ronda santis went from The Shining Star
of Maga to the Oscar the Grouch living
in a trash can and it is a remarkable
feat to be honest well it's because it
denies his Origins look Ronda santis was
a completely unknown obscure Congressman
with a bad haircut and a bad suit who
was struggling in single digits in a
race for governor he was lifted out of
political obscurity by Donald Trump uh
62 Republican County chairman the entire
Republican state apparatus every elected
Republican the Florida legislature every
member of the Congressional Delegation
who Republican except for Matt Gates had
endorsed Adam putam so Rond just owed
his nomination to Donald Trump and then
Trump changed his schedule in the last 3
weeks of the 2018 campaign to return to
Florida three times and literally drag
him over the Finish Line wow uh I didn't
think that voters cared about this you
know what I was wrong voters do care
about this they care about loyalty they
care about gratitude Ron was 42 years
old he couldn't have waited now I think
the flaws in his candidacy would have
shown up in 2028 anyway but he he's not
a viable candidate for 2028 now he could
have tried to play it more like VI did
which would have required him to one not
attack Donald Trump in these ridiculous
ways and then he actually would have had
to have bowed out it would have been a
weird campaign from the GetGo
considering how long he would people
were considering him he was the favorite
in the betting odds in January of 2023
yeah leading in the polls he was leading
in the polls talk about throwing that
all in the garbage and for what but but
I do want to
stress it was it was uh like me and many
others we we we were like we like Ron
but his campaign is being run by
children and whenever we would say
something like guys you need to fix this
what will be the response of his
campaign and I'm not talking about his
fans I'm talking about quite literally
his staff to attack potential allies and
insult them it was it was unusual I mean
I think and and maybe you have a better
insight into this but so much of the
disantis campaign to me seemed like it
was that pressure that we heard I kept
hearing this over and over again well he
has to run now because if he if he wait
Waits you have to strike while the iron
is hot if he waits it'll his uh name
will lose momentum and it'll fall off
and he can never have any big
opportunities which seemed
counterintuitive me counterintuitive to
me given that Trump had really boosted
his career if he had been loyal which is
what you hear over and over again when
Trump supporters are interviewed by the
New York Times by anyone else they say
I've been voting for Trump for this long
and I know that he can do good things
and I want to stick with him they value
loyalty and it seems like that pressure
to move uh his political career forward
against this this obvious call to
loyalty well he first of all he's got
two more years as Governor which he
could have distinguished himself if he
had gone out and campaigned hard for
Donald Trump he would he he could have
earned his support he could have been
next in line now he's got a gigantic
problem we have a term limitation of two
years there's a senate seat up in 2028
but how does he raise the money what
fulcrum does he have to raise the money
he's going to have a recalcitrant
legislature now because they resent the
fact that he's been missing we have an
insurance uh crisis we have a utility
rate crisis we have a venol crisis
where's Ron Ron's nowhere to be found
you know what this is this is Donald
Trump is a is a the lead singer in a
rock band charting every every every
week with a new single he finds this guy
to play bass the bass players is
standing on stage thinking like man they
love me I should start my own band so he
quits to start his own band and
everyone's like what ever happened to
that guy that's where he's headed wild
it's weird he he struck while the iron
was
warm he miscalculated the temperature
here but that I mean that's sad look I
it's no secret that I've been a Critic
of his wife I think she drove this
decision I think she was tremendously
ambitious and she misread the moment it
was not his time he had plenty of time
so can he recover from this like does he
have a a place moving forward in the
America first magga movement or could be
very much up to him but I mean look he
had a super majority in legislature
let's recognize he paid a million dollar
essentially a bribe to the speaker of
the house it's a legal bribe because he
gives a million dollars to his political
action committee and they changed the
state law so that only one person who
holds State office can run for federal
office without giving up their state
office so if I was in the state house
and I want to run for Congress I have to
resign but not Ronda santis he can run
for president while remaining uh
governor of Florida changing the law
just for him was a bad idea to begin oh
yeah he went to Iowa during a state of
emergency in Florida that was that was
the last nail in the coffin for me I I
had been defending like look well we
know he's good on policy he did well in
Florida but his campaign's bad and then
I found out he's in Iowa it was a
blizzard we we were were you in Iowa by
by chance no I was not but but I
remember it well we were we were in Iowa
minus you know 15° or whatever stores
are all closed heavy snow and Ron's like
I should be here instead of my home
state which is under a state of
emergency that he declared he flies in
declares flies out I was like wow that's
their election of Duty I thought it was
weird when he went to Japan and was
pretending that he wasn't about to
campaign you know like there were lots
of things that sort of felt disingenuous
and I'm not here to be I mean I'm not a
huge there are there were some things
about his campaign like some of his
immigration stuff that I thought was
interesting ultimately he never was who
I was going to vote for um but I think
what's worse is that we're sort of uh
stealing our future I I think ultimately
four more years of trump and then who
comes after after that there has to be a
legacy of people to fill these seats
when people are term Li limited and
can't move on thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net